نحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد اشعل ماسك ملك
شركه تويتر ضجه واسعه بعد كشف رسائل
الكترونيه داخليه حول ما حدث داخل الشركه
عندما قررت ايقاف قصه صحيفه عن جهاز
الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص بهنتر نجل الرئيس
الامريكي توبايدين قبيلانتخابات الرئاسه
عام 2020 حيث كان يعتقد انه الجهاز همم
معلومات عن استخدام ابن الرئيس الحالي
لنفوظها السياسي لممارسه اعمال في دول
اخرى وبدلا من نشر مجموعه من الوثائق
للجمهور اشهر ماسك الى سلسله تغريدات
الصحفي
الذي يتم تزويده برسائل بريد الكتروني
بشان ما كان معروفا عن الحادث واكد
تغريدات من هذا الصحفي اكدت انه في
الساعات الاولى بعد ان نشري قصه الصحيفه
تصارع موظفات تويتر مع مخاوف من احتمال
وجود عمليه قرصنه روسيه
لصور من شاشه محدثات نشرتها تايبي شكك
البعض في اساس القرار وحذروه من ان تويتر
ساتتهم وستتهم بتحيسا ضد المحفظين في حين
قال اخرون داخل الشركه ان الظروف المحيطه
بقصه غير بوس غير واضحه
واوصوا بالحذر ورغم ان اي لون ماسك افترض
في تغريده له مؤخرا وجوده تدخل حكومي في
عدم النشر محتويات كمبيوتر نجم فقد اكد
الصحفي والعكس تماما وانه لم يكن هناك
دليل على وجود اي تدخل رسمي
[موسيقى]
نفهم ما يحدث وما يريده ايرون ماسك خاصه
مع ضيوفنا من اورلاندو تو حرب ريس وتحالف
الامريكي ل ااا شرق او شرق او سطل
الديمقراطيه اهلا باكوا منه يوصل احمد
الحمصي الباحث في شان الامريكي اهلا بكم
يا اهل الكريمين ومعاكم في الواقع نحاول
ان نفهم ما الذي يريده ماسك هل يريد كشف
الحقائق هل يريد تكريسه حريه التعبير ام
ماسك يلعب لعبه سياسيه سيد احمد ما رايك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته احب نبدا
باللقاء التحيه عليك الصيدليه وعلى
التوم اللي يعني دائما يكرمنا بكرام
اخلاقه ويحرجنا بانه يبدا بالتحقيقه
اولا
بالنسبه الي ماسك اليس من الواضح نوايا
لهم هناك اتجاهين محتملين الاتجاه الاول
انه فعلا يريد دعم المحافظين انه يعني
تحول الى اداه محافظه يعني هذا طبعا ليس
شيء ليست مشكله كبيره او هذا حقه ولكنه
ااه الاحتمال الثاني انه الهدف اصلا
اقتصادي وليس سياسي بمعنى انه يريد ترويج
تويتر
يرى هو انها لا تستخدمه بكثافه من اليمين
المحافظ بشكل اخر نستطيع ان نقول انه يريد
تحويل تويتر الى فيسبوك اخر لانه نعرف ان
السياسات في اسمك التحريريه يعني تتعاطف
كثيرا مع اليمين هو قد يكون يريد ان يجعل
تويتر باموات ممثله
شريحه جديده من المستخدمين اه سيتم رايك
هل ترى كضيفي بان اهداف ماسك الاساسيه
اقتصاديه ماليه كون رجل اعمال ناجح ام انا
ماسك همم يمكن ان تكون له يد في السياسه
لبعض حتى ذهب بالاعتقاد بانه همم يروج
لفكره للضغط على الديمقراطيين من خلال هذا
الترويش
اهدين الكرام انا لا بتصور السيد ماسك اي
شخص امريكي يحاول ان يحمي حريه التعبير
اللي هو البند الاساسي بالدستور الامريكي
اول باند اساسي بالدستور الامريكانيه ومن
هذه الناحيه ايه ماسك معظم الامريكي
حسب القوانين الامريكيه
الاعلام والمعلومات اللي هي دار النشر
الجرائد والتلفزيونيه وهذه غير محميه من
الحكومه الامريكيه اذا عملت اي اي معلومات
خاطئه عن اي شخص
ان يرفع دعوه ضد جريده التلفزيون اما منصه
همم الانترنت لاخر قانون كان معروف بعنون
96 هذه المناصه هي بس المعلومات تعطى واخذ
منها ما في حدا عم بيحررها غير هو الشخص
الذي يقرا هذا المعلومات ومن هنا بالذات
اتى السيد الى الماسك وقال حريه التحرير
لهذه المنصه يجب ان تكون بالاشخاص الذين
يقرؤون الاعلام ولا لاحد الغايه منه ولا
يجب ان يكون تواطئ بين اي حزب او ولا
الحكومه ولا ايمنصه ان كانت فيسبوك اما
تويتر هلا لانه عنده قدره قدره شرائيه ب
44 مليار دولار استطاع ان يشتري هذه
المنصه واليوم يحاول ان يحررها من اي
تواطئ لي تعود هذه المنصه الى الشعب وليس
الى اي
مجموعهم يحق له ان يشتري كذلك اسرار الناس
وينشرها همم لما تتحدث عن حريق تعبير
واواد مشاركه كذلك استاذ احمد في هذا
النقاش يعني لما نتحدث عن تكريس حريه
التعبير ما سيقول البعض بان هناك خط فيع
بين حريه التعبير وبين تجاوز همم
الحريات همم لاشخاص في المقابل بمعنى ان
ماسك همم يحلل لنفسه ما يحرمه على غيرك
البعض منعه من التغريد لانه تكلم بمصطلحات
عنيفه وتكلما بحريه لم يستصخها ماسك فمن
يقدر الموضوع كيف يقاس الموضوع سيد احمد
خليني ابدا معك
هذه هي المشكله يعني ماسك يرفع شعار حريه
التعبير ولكن عندما نرى سواء سلوكياته او
حتى مراسلته التي كشفت اثناء قضيه شراء
تويتر نجد ان الفكره مشوه ليس لديه سياق
واضح يعني ليس لديه تفكير واضح حول هذا
الامر من المعروف لاي شخص يعمل في هذا
المجال ان من المستحيل ان تضمن حريه
التعبير بحدود القانون كما يقول مصر لانك
عندما تفعل ذلك
سيتحول تويتر الى مستنقع شبيه بالجامد
مثلا لان لن يكون به ناجحه لا تجاريا ولا
تاثير يعني سيغادرها الاغلبيه همم وسيطر
الى فرد درجه درجه ما من التحرير والرقابه
يعني راينا مثلا يعني همم اقف في حساب
ثاني بينما كان يسلم يخالف القانون هو
يعني ماسك في تبريره يقول بانه حرض على
العنف بينما هو كل ما فعله يعني نشر صوره
الصليب المعقول ليش مو صلاه الصليب
المعقول رغم انه
ثقافه الامريكيه لانه لا يخالف القانون
فبالتالي هناك هناك يعني عدم اتساق في
سياسه ماسك مما يدفعنا الى الاعتقاد ان لا
انها له اهداف اخرى حريه التعبير ليست
هدفه الفعله هو من هو الذي هدف سياسي فعلا
يريد دعم اليمين واما ان الذي هدف تجاري
يدخل على تويتر وكانه يريد القول يعني مع
المعذره لماسك يعني ياخذ بعانه الاعتبار
ما يحب ماسك وما يكره همم سيد توم هل يمكن
ما نشر تغريدات فيما يخص موضوع ابن بادن
ان ينشر مثلا انت حصل على ذلك همم وثائق
تخص ترامب موجوده في منزله هنا يمكن
الحديث عن الحريه التعبير يمكن ان يفعلها
تعتقد
طبعا يجب ان يكشف كل هذه الاسرار لانه هذا
ملك الشعب وليس ملكه الخاص ولا ملك الدوله
هذا ملك الشعب ولكن الذي يجب
تقوم به الحكومه اما المشرعين الذين
ننتخبهم اليوم وخاصه قادمين على سنتين
بانكسار مجلس نواب للجمهوريين ومجلس
الشيوخ للديمقراطيين هذا افضل وقت ان يعود
النظر بالقانون 230 ويعدل في لانه القانون
230 كان قبل الفيسبوك وقبل التويتر وقبل
وقبل كل هذه السوشيال ميديا الموجوده يجب
على المشرعين ان يكونوا بتشريع قوانين
جديده كما يكون في انفصام بالمجتمع
الامريكي وحتى بالمجتمع الدولي واي دوله
تكرر على حساب امريكا اما او دولي تلغي
تويتر انا بتصور المسؤولين همم العنايه
المسؤوليه كبيره بهذه السنه القادمه
بعد هذه الوثائق بعد شريحه في الدماغ وكل
ما يطرحه من افكار سنتابع كل تغريداته وكل
تحركاته شكرا لكم جزيلا الشكر منه
اورلاندو وتوم حرب ريس وتحالف الامريكي
الشرق وسطيله الديمقراطيه وشكرا كذلك لك
من هيوستنا احمد الحنطي البحث في شان
الامريكي شكرا لكم